being the urban dictionary today like
you know people get look at me like
who's this guy don't get me wrong don't
get me wrong yeah okay
it's just that here's the deal dude
I've known about you for a while okay
you're lit well I got a funny story
about when we had an encounter actually
you and I did yeah I got it but let me
just say that's okay
and I know what you do I know you
represent and I'm not saying that you're
the spokesperson for you know urban
dictionary the urban dictionary okay but
can I just say you know my gateway all
right you are a representative a little
bit and I'm learning through you I'm
happy to be a thank you
yeah when did we meet I mean I would see
you once in a while just talk a town but
then doors one time I saw you at Silver
Lake ramen and then I was just sitting
there with my homey and you're passing
by I don't even know you that well at
the time yeah yeah and I say yo what's
up Bobby and he's like yo what's up guys
bla bla and just kind of like hovered
over our table and then you kind of like
kneeled down yeah yeah you told us like
a really deep secret what was it oh you
literally was like yo I got this girl
pregnant me it was that you were you
telling us this was like and we were
just like I didn't eat any he was a
psych I don't know what to do like she
would I but it was like the strangest
cereal like it's like five years ago
like I just got like a noodle hanging
down and I'm just like no I just don't
know Bobby that was approximately five
years ago for you so definitely yeah
more than three years ago okay so five
days oh what the [ __ ] dude but it was
weird because there was no Segway it was
a layer what's up Bobby
yeah those know like - or
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I mean how many
people did I'm in shops that you go to
talk Oh he literally just I want to
apologize I want apologize to the world
are you first I'm so sorry
first all right sorry I'm so sorry
okay I do these things when when like
crazy things happen or like when
personal things happen where I have to
blurt it out to the world when my dad
has a stroke I took a photo of him in
about to die right and then one night I
was at a week couple weeks later I was
at the Comedy Store and I was sitting
next to Mary Ellen rice cub from 24 okay
yeah my dad just had a stroke and you
know my dad's in the bed like this see
why the [ __ ] you show me that and I go I
don't know why like I take you know it's
the same thing that I did to you right
and it is a [ __ ] I don't do it as
much I don't think I do it anymore
I try to think not to do it but I have
done it in the past I don't know what
that's about
maybe you need is that a bad thing
though it's very vulnerable to no I
think it's yeah you need a sounding
board I think you need somebody a
perfect stranger like someone like a
therapist you'd like dump all your
thoughts right because here I don't know
this kid right and it's woodles right
and I'm telling him the deepest like
darkest secretive thing for no [ __ ]
reason to [ __ ] him up or Ismail up but
first that was like a joke or no I was
like does he think I'm somebody else and
then and then second we were just like
yo this guy is like you know we we know
you're like Bobby Lee's crazy you know
we were like this guy's an artist
[Applause]
changing I'm not like an art weirdo
artist type that would do [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah that's what my pose like yeah
but you know what let me say something
right now that is not a good way to live
and here's the thing is is that I'm
literally I'm being honest as the
realest thing I've said is I don't want
to do any of that [ __ ] anymore
I all those little defense mechanisms or
little things that to shock people were
to [ __ ] people's day up I used to do
that you know and it's like I don't want
to do that anymore I want to be a normal
guy hello yeah I want to be you know
flexing lit yeah and washed out you know
man what I want to be normal I want to
be normal I want to be a regular guy and
you know what I'm so sorry I did that
for to you oh no no we didn't take it we
didn't like ruin our day you know yeah
but you know what it's not right for her
give my name my hope right now five
years we finally meet the we don't have
a child okay so yeah yeah yeah we had
that one of those and um it's so weird I
think now when you say that story I kind
of vaguely remember it you know I
remembered maybe doing something like
that
it just brought me back and that's just
not cool man you know I apologize I know
you didn't [ __ ] up your day no it wasn't
like all the other times we ran into
each other you told me another like I've
literally gone up to guys I don't know
yeah and high school sucked dick yeah
like why would anyone want to know that
after the first year right you know I
was molested by a guy with Down syndrome
like some strange 20 the salad I [ __ ]
you know tender greens that's a Bubba
right and they're like oh
yeah but I don't want to do that anymore
I want to be a normal guy so I so I
apologize
[Music]